you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
breaking its brexit farming promises the
government's plans for more sustainable
farming are criticized by wildlife
charities
and must try harder the chair of the
climate change committee tells us that
after cop 26 the government needs to
walk the talk on climate and match
ambition with policy
the real issue is when the rubber hits
the road when you actually get on with
doing those things and my job is to make
sure that the government does those
things
as delhi authorities close schools
indefinitely due to dangerous levels of
air pollution we ask if we're taking the
issue seriously enough
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now public money for public goods that's
the theory behind a post-brexit subsidy
scheme for farmers and today the
government took a step further in
telling farmers how they'd be paid to
improve the quality of their soil in
order to both benefit biodiversity and
mitigate against the effects of climate
change because soil is crucially
important not only for growing crops and
feeding livestock but also because it's
a huge carbon sink and if soil isn't
taken care of the carbon is released and
will add to the greenhouse gas emissions
which cause global warming so let's find
out a bit more
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
well sky's political correspondent kate
mccann joins me now from westminster so
kate tell us more about the plans and
what the reaction has been to them
well the sustainable farming incentive
will replace the basic payment scheme
and essentially the premise at the heart
of this is that the government believes
that it should be less prescriptive that
you should trust farmers to make some of
these decisions because they say george
eustis says that farmers will make
better decisions when the value to them
is increased and ultimately those
decisions lead to better outputs for
climate change and the environment too
now examples of that are no-till farming
for example where some farmers have
found that doing that means that they
don't have to use as many chemicals on
their land and ultimately it's far
better for the soil there's less erosion
and they can reuse those fields more
intensively so the government is trying
to push people to nudge them if you like
to make these choices rather than really
prescriptively telling them or finding
them if they don't but campaigners say
that the problem with that is that there
will be gaps because this new system at
the moment focuses on soil there are
three main areas being announced today
the other areas will be announced later
so for example on hedgerows those
measures will come in in 2023 on
orchards they will be in 2025 and
campaigners say in the time between the
old system and the new system some
farmers might exploit those gaps for
short-term incentives so they say that's
unfair for farmers who want to use the
scheme for good now the government says
george's his family have been farming in
cornwall for six decades he says that
most farmers will make the right choices
that many already are and this system
trusts them to do that rather than
penalizing them
kate thanks very much indeed
now let's take a look at some of those
other climate news and schools and
colleges have been ordered to close in
india's capital city until further
notice due to high levels of air
pollution delhi's city government had
reopened schools last week after closing
them for 15 days because of poor air
quality a ban on construction will
continue and diesel trucks with
non-essential goods are also barred from
entering the city while delhi
authorities have hired an extra 700
natural gas buses to encourage people to
use public transport
poverty poor infrastructure and an
over-reliance on rainfall are behind the
famine in madagascar according to
climate scientists more than a million
people are affected by serious hunger
according to the world food programme
who had described conditions in the
south of the country as the world's
first climate-induced famine a report
from world weather attribution concluded
that madagascar's worst drought in four
decades has been caused by natural
climate variability with climate change
only playing a small part
a period of global cooling triggered by
volcanic activity may have caused one of
the most severe mass extinctions in
history a new study looking at the
effects of volcanic ash and lava on
oceans found that 84 of ocean species
were made extinct by the cooling event
450 million years ago researchers found
two exceptionally large volcanic events
coincided very closely with two peaks in
glaciation and extinction
now uk efforts on climate change should
focus on strengthening delivery of the
net zero strategy rather than inflating
the gap between ambition and
implementation that's the conclusion of
the climate change committee the
independent body set up to advise the
government on climate policy well in a
post-cop assessment published today they
say that despite world-leading targets
the uk government still doesn't have the
policies in place to support that
ambition well earlier i spoke to lord
dieben chair of the climate change
committee and started by asking him in
which areas of policy the government is
falling short
it's got its program but it hasn't
actually started many of those issues so
we've got to have
much tougher building regulations for
uh for our homes we've got to move on on
changing our heating arrangements we've
got to have a land use system a way of
helping farmers and land owners to use
the land more effectively so that it can
take the carbon out of the atmosphere
and put it down in the soil and in trees
all that we've got to have much more
clearly spelt out and the government
starting on those programs well yes
because the government would argue
wouldn't it that it's one of the first
countries in the world to set net zero
into law they would point out that
they've got some of the most ambitious
emissions targets in the world and they
also say they're one of the first
countries to produce those detailed
plans to meet net zero are you saying
that's not fair
no i thought that's absolutely true and
i would congratulate the government on
doing that but uh
the real issue is when the rubber hits
the road when you actually get on with
doing those things and my job is to make
sure that the government does those
things and at the moment we don't have
those detailed policies we need to have
those and we need to have them actually
under operation this is not a criticism
of the government it's saying this now
has to be done and i'm looking to the
government to do it and the other thing
it has to do of course is to complete
its year as president of the cop26
because much of what will be the success
of that has got to be achieved in the
coming months so it's got to give the
backing to adult sharma who has been a
great success to finish the job
one of the areas that i think the ccc
has raised as one of concern is this
issue of fossil fuel subsidies and
leaders at cop 26 agreed to phase out
what was described as inefficient fossil
fuel subsidies but this is a difficult
issue isn't it the government here might
argue that they need to manage the
transition to renewables very carefully
not least for security of energy supply
but also because there are a huge number
of jobs tied up in this area
yes that's why it's got to be done
properly but the idea that you
talk about efficient fuel subsidy seems
to us to be quite nonsense what we have
to do is to recognize that we will need
further fossil fuels between now and
2035 and some thereafter but what the
fuel industry has got to show is
precisely how much
they can already supply from their
present sources
no good openly new sources unless
there's a very good reason for it and so
far we have seen no good reason
what about individuals behavior would
you like to see the government coming
forward with advice for individuals on
say how much they should fly or how much
meat they should eat
now i much prefer the government to come
forward with information for people so
that they know how to make those choices
there are an awful lot of people out
there who really do want to make the
proper choice and for example on meat
yes we ought to eat less meat but we
ought to eat better meat and the best
meat to eat is british produced meat
because it has the lowest carbon
footprint of any meat produced in the
world i'd like to see the government
making sure that we don't import meat
from countries where the carbon
footprint is much greater and then
undercut farmers producing that in this
country our trade policy has got to be
improved there are a whole range of
things the government can do without
being dictatorial
stay tuned coming up after the break
i'll be joined by the climate activist
day zagarji and author and journalist
david wallace wells and we're going to
be discussing if air pollution is being
taken seriously enough and what the
future of food could look like
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate activist days agi and the author
and journalist david wallace well so
good to see both good evening to you and
first of all we can talk about air
pollution because it's a deadly issue
for people in countries around the world
and as we heard earlier schools and
colleges have again been closed in the
indian capital new delhi due to poor air
equality and closer to home there were
protests in the serbian capital belgrade
over air pollution just this week it's
europe's most polluted big city
according to the european environment
agency for those forced to breathe in
toxic air every day it can seem that
little is being done to address this
issue so let's talk about a little bit
more uh david wallis wells this is
something that you've written
extensively about so are we taking
pollution seriously enough do you think
the short answer is absolutely not it
seems to me to be among the biggest
public health and environmental crises
of our time
in some ways a bigger problem even than
climate change the mortality
statistics are overwhelming most data
suggests at least 7 million people
perhaps as many as 10 or more million
people a year dying from air pollution
most of that from the burning of fossil
fuels that is an unfathomable
amount of death and much more suffering
besides i think we're not doing nearly
enough in part because many of um many
of us living in places like uk and the
us don't regard the humanity of people
living in places like india
adequately but also because we regard
the status quo in which we ourselves in
our relatively clean air are suffering
as acceptable simply because it is the
status quo and don't think about what
kind of a better cleaner healthier
future we could be building and then
also more prosperous one if we took the
opportunity to more rapidly transition
off of those deadly fuels and into a
much greener cleaner future and dave i
can see you nodding there and i think
you've got some personal experience you
feel that you've been affected by
pollution don't you
oh yes i have i have grown up in an area
of where most kids in primary schools
have asthma and i grew up thinking that
was totally normal which it isn't um i'm
living in an area where we have an
incinerator and we watch the incinerator
burn over a community that's mostly
populated by black and brown people of
working-class backgrounds this is the
reality of air pollution it's not just
something that affects our health but it
affects our developmental stages it
affects communities as a whole and the
fact that it's allowed to be continued
for so long it's disgusting
in places like for example in lewisham
in london it's six times over the legal
levels of air pollution it's literally
illegal to breathe the air that we're
breathing currently and we are not even
the worst when is it going to be enough
when are enough people going to die for
governments to care
well yes and that's interesting isn't it
you quoted that figure from the world
health organization david saying that
around 7 million people die from air
pollution annually but as days pointed
out it's not just in in some of those
poorer developing countries it is also
in big wealthy cities as well so do you
think that people are waking up to this
they're beginning to
i think they're beginning to a lot of
the scariest research is now just a few
years old and it tends to take a little
while for that kind of stuff to sort of
circulate and percolate and and begin to
change public opinion and public policy
i do think the more we talk about it the
more we note it um the more alarmed
we'll be and i do think the research is
going to continue moving very much in
this direction the world health
organization just a couple months ago
changed its threshold this the standard
that it says is safe and they cut it in
half which means it used to be the case
that 90 percent of the world was living
in places with dangerously polluted air
now it's something closer to 90 and 90
percent which means almost nobody is
safe and in fact the researchers doing
that work say possibly even that safe
threshold isn't safe they just haven't
really done the work yet on the lower
levels of air pollution to know but they
suspect that as it was with lead
pollution
no level of air pollution will be safe
at all and we'll still be seeing um
death from pollution but also
as days was pointing out um
developmental problems um cognitive
problems behavioral problems
produced in part at least from this
pollution which is an elective um
problem we could be burning much less
fossil fuel we could be
burning much less farmland these are
choices we make in part through policy
which are killing at least seven and you
know the figures i trust are more like
10 million people a year which is again
just an absolutely staggering figure it
means 100 million deaths a decade it
means 400 million deaths in my lifetime
that is um the kind of thing that we
should be orienting an entire moral
politics around not one that we should
be treating as an environmental
afterthought okay i'm going to move us
on to our next subject now because we've
got a lot we want to squeeze in and
we're going to talk about how we farm
because it has a huge impact on the
environment whether it's soil
degradation from growing crops all the
emissions from flying produce around the
world so the future of farming and the
food we eat is a big issue and days the
government's announced today that
farmers will be paid to look after
england's soil
which is an important carbon store of
course how
important a moment is that is this a big
step to making farming more sustainable
i think it's a vital step but i don't
think it's big step and i don't think
it's big enough for the same government
that calls themselves climate leaders
every two seconds um i
see that giving and empowering farmers
to be able to farm their own land and to
make sure it's regenerative and purpose
is so important but soil degradation
definitely is important but it's only
one part of the farming system that has
to change we have to start looking away
from monocultural farming that's causing
issues within biodiversity and the soil
in itself you know we have to start
looking at how do we build regeneration
um and into our farming systems and
that's really important not just for the
farmers and our environment but also for
the food we eat for the nourishment we
get these are all things that will be
greatly affected if we don't change the
way that we farm well yes and it's such
a complex issue isn't it david we can
only touch on some of the issues but not
only has farming got a role to play in
helping mitigate against climate change
protecting the soil bin example but
farming is also affected hugely by
climate change certainly in in some
parts of the world
yeah i think most scientists believe
that through direct temperature effects
most crops will have we'll see declines
in their yields over the next few
decades um you also have to deal with
the fact that climate change is making
pesticide infestation more common it's
making weather patterns more
erratic both in the case of you know
droughts and heat waves but also in the
case of flooding all of which can be
devastating for crops
last year in the u.s american farmers
made more money from insurance payouts
than they did from actually selling
their crops to the market
and when you think globally and how
interconnected we are how globalized our
food system is um it's no it's not
really the case that um for most parts
of the world you know a crop failure um
in one in one corner of the planet
doesn't mean anything it affects um
everything even if it's not directly
affecting the amount of food that we'll
be having in a place like the us the uk
it will affect food prices which um are
going to be it's that that is a
difficult problem for those who are
already living um on the edge of of um
hardship with food or who have a hard
time getting the food they need as we've
seen with so many other
products over the last few months the
global supply chain is really fragile um
the food supply chain is as fragile and
climate change is going to make it much
harder to move that food around the
world sorry to cut in i just want to
give days one more answer on the issue
of imported food 80 percent of food in
the uk is imported i mean that's going
to have an impact in terms of air miles
but also
some farms in other countries might have
lower environmental standards there are
so many issues here days aren't there
exactly and i think we have to remember
like especially as an island we are so
vulnerable to the changes within food
systems and the way uh imports come in
um and i think we noticed that with
covert so if we don't have the right
soil if we don't have the right
processes to grow food at home as well
in order to meet the demands what
happens if there is another shortage
what where does that leave us where does
that leave the average person where does
that leave the people who are most
excited okay
daisy
david wallace wells thank you so much
dealing with very big issues and rather
a small amount of time we appreciate it
thank you
thank you well we are all done for the
evening but do stay tuned here for sky
news tonight because sky news goes
inside the lab studying the new covert
19 variant but that's it from me do stay
tuned lots coming up again tomorrow see
you next time